derrière ces arbres sur les hauteurs de
la lozère se cache un ennemi pas comme
les autres le lourd refait parler de lui
depuis quelques mois il rôde déjà 6000
brebis tuées en france depuis un an
mais donc dit ici j'ai beaucoup et elle
avaient été vidées boyau tout était
sorti et c'est le loup olivier est
éleveur de brebis à chavalier un petit
village au nord du département et ses
pâtures sont aujourd'hui en plein
territoire du loup depuis cet été
la bête lui a déjà pris une vingtaine de
ces ovins l'état de guerre chaque jour
on serre ne sais pas ça qu'on va trouver
on ne sait pas ce qu'il faut laisser la
place au bout et et nous arrêter là
c'est la question quoi l'animal espèce
protégée est de retour comme sur une
bonne partie du sud est de la france
un deux trois individus en lozère
difficile d'apercevoir le loup comme sur
ses rares images amateurs venus d'italie
il aurait franchi les alpes pour
recoloniser l'hexagone on en compte près
de 280 aujourd'hui en france alors la
grogne s'empare des éleveurs des
manifestations pour exprimer leur
ras-le-bol et surtout leurs peurs en
référence au bonnet rouge breton les
bonnes et noir ne veulent pas du loup il
serait présent dans une trentaine de
départements français des vosges aux
pyrénées-orientales en 2012
il aurait attaqué 1800 fois
dans les villages de lozère on sonne
l'alertent un collectif de paysans s'est
monté derrière andré barret le maire de
hures-la-parade ici l'equilibre vie
pastorale vie sauvage
on n'y croit pas on n'a plus envie nous
les agriculteurs d'être le terrain de
jeu des environnementalistes c'est
terrible lynx loups ours vautours même
si ça pose moins de problème ledun le
cerf le chevreuil fait que c'est un
extra tous ces animaux là il veut que
chez le paysage j'ai pour habitude de
dire donc abandonner il faut quand même
se poser la question qu'est ce qu'on
fait qui c'est qui nourrit la france et
comment commence on nourrit nos citoyens
loin des yeux loin du coeur on va
chercher de la nourriture en
nouvelle-zélande mais ailleurs et en
faisant ça ceux qui protègent
l'environnement en réalité favorisent
l'élevage industriel donc réfléchissez à
ce qu'on fait à moins donné la culture
locaux on devrait être entendu
sur ses terres au nord de la lozère on
connaît bien le loup au xviiie siècle
la peur est à son comble la bête du
gévaudan fait légende un animal
s'attaque aux bergers et en l'espace de
trois ans une centaine de personnes et
tué
superstition ou machination humaine
aujourd'hui encore l'animal mythique a
laissé son empreinte au moyen âge de
nous a pu représenter une menace pour la
france parce qu'il y a eu de nombreux
cas de nous engager et un orage et
pourrait être dangereux pour l'homme ce
qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui un
sylvain est le spécialiste des loups en
lozère un amoureux avant tout il
s'occupe de 98 canidé dans ce parc
animalier
alors les grelots depuis près de 30 ans
derrière des clôtures le loup vite en
captivité aucun ne s'en est échappée
pour le soigneur les loups en liberté
c'est possible il faut simplement que
les agriculteurs revoient leurs méthodes
d'élevage avant l'éradication du loup la
disparition du lynx et le fait qu'il y
ait très peu d'ours en france on
protéger les troupeaux avec on va dire
pendant à peu près 60 ans la disparition
des super prédateur on avait changé
cette façon de protéger
on avait surtout changer cette façon
travail on ne protège plus les troupeaux
en fait l'eau autant qu'opportuniste en
tant que super prédateur cherche à
faciliter à partir du moment où des
troupeaux seront protégés eh bien ils
cibleront leurs attaques sur un sur un
chevreuil sur un sanglier sur un surf
hénaff et non pas sur sur une brebis
partout où il ya du pastoralisme le lou
doit être exclu il faut avoir une
véritable efficience sur le
développement d'espèces nous on ne veut
plus qu'elle se développe on veut
qu'elle régresse largement sauvée on ne
tient pas compte des enclos et parquet
donc pour nous quelque part on ne
cherche plus à protéger le loup on
cherche bien en sauvagement de la nature
chez les défenseurs du loup on voit dans
ce retour une chance pour la
biodiversité
sylvain ne veut pas croire à une
nouvelle éradication symbole de gâchis
environnemental
c'est une chance qu'il puisse y avoir à
nouveau des loups en liberté sur notre
sol que le loup fassent l'objet de faim
qu'ils puissent être pointés comme étant
un peu le bouc émissaire c'est certain
mais il n'est pas responsable de la de
tous les problèmes des éleveurs c'est
évident
en europe le canis lupus est une espèce
protégée par la convention de berne de
en mai dernier c'est un plan loup un
plan national qui est mise en place pour
réconcilier pro et anti loup pas assez
convaincant pour le sénateur alain
bertrand il fait voter au sénat la
création de zones de protection
renforcée contre le loup un texte
bienvenu ici chez jean-luc ses brebis
ont subi des attaques à quelques mètres
de la ferme
l'année dernière on en a une
juste là au fond de neuf cette montagne
et il a été vu d'ailleurs loué par une
dame qui chassait son exploitation et
sur le causse méjean au sud de la lozère
350 hectares de pâtures 600 brebis
jean-luc garde en mémoire une date 1956
cette année là le dernier loup du
département est tué alors depuis ce jour
les éleveurs qui se sont installés
n'avait pas imaginé son retour en fait
nous on a perdu trois brebis
je vais on est des agriculteurs on n'est
pas ce qu'on a on perdu le plus mais
c'est quand même souci permanent de la
nuit vous dormez pas et que vous avez
comme vous avez le loup vous pensez
qu'ils ont revue vous pouvez pas dormir
même si jean luc s'est muni d'un fameux
chiens patous capable de tenir tête aux
loups rien n'y fait vous savez on a un
endroit assez sec le causse où les
brebis match plutôt la nuit à une
journée à l'hommage pas vraiment et
cette bête nous amer dans la nuit on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas faire voitures
n'auront lui comme moi
nos modalités d'exploitation ovine ne
permettent pas la présence du loup donc
qu'il faut cartonner le loup sur les
crêtes les alpes ou sur les crêtes les
pyrénées là on peut regrouper des
troupeaux on peut mettre les barrières
électriques
on peut faire tout le temps des choses
ici c'est trop compliqué c'est pas
possible ça avoue-t-il et la disparition
progressive d'une forme traditionnelle
d'agriculture sur l'écorcé notamment et
dans les cévennes qui nous vaut
aujourd'hui pour exemple le classement à
l'unesco pour qu'on parle d'elle ou à
paris on attire quelques uns un chemin
de tête quelques sourires ces sujets
c'est dramatique pour les éleveurs
c'est peut être mis en place on voulait
mettre deux tireurs du coup voilà et
qu'il peut surveiller là bas il peut
surveiller la de retour chez olivier
l'éleveur du nord de la lozère
aujourd'hui il reçoit la visite d'un
agent de la direction du territoire
il vient contrôler l'avancement des
travaux pour le mirador
après les attaques l'agriculteur a
décidé de se protéger dans le cadre du
plan loup le préfet lui a permis
d'utiliser le tir de défense tiré au
fusil pour effrayer le loup ou l'abattre
s'il devient dangereux l'objectif c'est
effectivement de continuer pour la
france à respecter ses engagements
internationaux par rapport au statut
d'espèce protégée qu'est le loup mais
surtout d'accompagner des éleveurs
lorsqu il y a la présence du loup et des
attaques
donc on essaie de trouver un équilibre
qui est pas toujours évident et pour ça
le plan loup met à la disposition des
éleveurs et des services de l'état un
certain nombre d'outils plus loin autres
mesures du plan loup olivier a accroché
une petite boîte dans cet arbre un
cerbère donc là c'est un dispositif qui
fait partie aussi des mesures de
protection on est là dans une phase dite
d'effarouchement c'est à dire que
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de faire fuir
le loup ou de lui faire peur avec en
faisant du bruit donc c'est un poste
radio qui fait du bruit pour essayer de
faire partir le loup et de lui dire bon
on va manger à karkwa voilà lui louer
malins ils arrivent à contourner ça
alors ça marche un certain nombre de
jours et après il se rend compte que ça
ne représente pas forcément un danger
pour lui donc il faut choisir une radio
que toute la nuit aussi une espèce
protégée
pourtant le plan loup prévoit bien des
tirs pour contrôler la colonisation 24
bête pourront être abattus sur le sol
français en 2014
dans chaque département c'est l'office
national de la chasse qui est chargé de
recenser les individus ça y est tu as
trouvé nos coûts mais intéressant pas
les âges on installe un piège photo à
deux pas de lait steve d'olivier passage
obligé de l'animal c'est le système de
radar et qui déclenche automatiquement
au passage dès qu'ils détectent
mouvement ça fait partie des des
dispositifs qui sont mis un autre à
notre disposition pour pour collecter
des indices de présence des animaux
confirmation faite pour l'instant en
lozère jamais plus d'un spécimen sur les
photos
on retrouve alain bertrand sur les
routes du département
est ce que le loup est vraiment
responsable de la faillite de cette
filière ovine
non le moule pour responsable c'est un
élément supplémentaire qui va se
rajouter aux difficultés de la filière
le sénateur continue de mener son
enquête cette fois il est au parc au
loup le parlementaire a voulu aller au
contact de cet animal très bel animal
qui aime pour novell qui est joli
d'autres voient qu il à 2000 et sting en
éveil en même temps c'est super animal
quoi je suis fan des chiennes en plus
elle est propriétaire ils ont une
différence de taille importante était
sujet à l'autre alors on n'échange pas
les sous-espèces un peu comme si on
parlait de rose avec des chiens
aujourd'hui 75% des français souhaite
protéger le nom et le revoir dans nos
forêts il n'y a pas d'un côté des
méchants qui veulent la tuer le loup
l'éradiquer
de l'autre côté les gentils qui le
protège et je le redis le loup à sa
place sur certains territoires à france
est bien délimité bien particulier pour
moi évidemment je peux avoir en tant
qu'éleveur de nous et en tant que
passionné de l'animal je peux je ne peux
pas voir autrement qu'avec la preuve qu
espérer qu'on puisse avoir des loups en
liberté sur notre sol même dans des
régions il n'y en a pas encore il faut
que l'espèce vival liberté là où elle
peut vivre sur le territoire national
voilà c'est ça la principale différence
le jour je serais capable de faire
pareil avec des loups sauvages et on
n'en est pas là à l'époque pour la
véritable casse tête
l'an passé sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
le lou a coûté à l'état 8 millions
d'euros pour financer les protections et
2 millions pour indemniser les éleveurs
en lozère on est encore bien loin du
grand méchant loup des frères grimm
mais pour l'heure il n'a pas fini de
recoloniser la france empruntant aux
forêts des dizaines de kilomètres en une
nuit
le lou a récemment été aperçue en
haute-marne dans les plaines de
champagne alors les grelots